so we have the motion of this object
which is thrown through the air and it's
modeled with this equation that's
provided there okay now just quickly
have a look at the equation what kind of
equation is it it's in the family of
quadratic functions this is worth
writing down by the way so we've got x
equals 20 t minus 5t squared now we
mentioned before I mentioned before we
were going to look at projectile motion
later on this is a projectile it's been
thrown upwards and it moves in the path
if you think about it over the course of
time it moves in a parabolic path up and
down but it's got that stationary point
up at the top we're going to prove that
that is the case by the time we get to
that part of the course but for now
we're just going to assume that it does
that okay so they provide you with this
equation they ask us to find a bunch of
things as functions of x from Part A
what are they asking for have a look
what's V so this is X dot this is the
first derivative of displacement with
respect to time so I'm gonna write V
because they've asked me to write it
down and I'm gonna say that is the
derivative of displacement with respect
to time okay do you need to write that
no you could go straight to
differentiating if you wanted to but I
don't know about you already in racing H
we've seen questions where it's like I
have five different derivatives flying
around I really like to describe really
explicitly what derivative I'm actually
working here okay
so Paul help me out what's the
derivative 20 minus 10 T thank you very
much okay there's my first derivative
there's velocity as a function of T type
they also asked us for X double dot X
double dot that is acceleration which I
get straight from this line right so can
you tell me what the acceleration is
it's just yeah negative 10 an upset that
20 becomes irrelevant and that's what
we've got okay so I found velocity I
found acceleration it says sure that the
ball is always accelerating downwards
accelerating downwards how do I read
that where do you get that from here
yeah it's the sign of this accelerate
here right so I would say since x
double-dot is always less than zero it's
negative ten all the time right it is
always accelerating downwards and you
can hear that a language that I alluded
to before this is vector language
because they say it's accelerating its
velocity is changing but then they also
have to describe the direction in which
it is changing it is accelerating in
that direction then sketch graphs of X V
and X double dot against T so when they
say against T they mean T is going to be
your horizontal axis for the whole thing
and we're going to use the vertical axis
to have less you all three graphs of
these at the same time can I give you a
minute to draw up your axes think
carefully about what kind of scale
you're going to need to you so you can
fit all three graphs one two three on
the same graph I'll give you a second to
put that together and then we'll compare
okay how do your graphs look yeah no
yeah give me a thumbs-up or thumbs-down
yeah it's a thinner is giving me we'd
curly fingers I don't know what that
means and I'm trying to interpret you
okay so let's just have a quick look at
this I've got my my X which you told me
before was a quadratic so it's a
parabola right I factorize it up here
just to make it easier for me to work
out what is going on that negative which
I chose to factorize out I didn't have
to factorize out but it reminds me oh
yes this thing is concave down I've got
the factorization was mainly so I could
work out the intercepts the T intercepts
which you can see a zero and four off of
that factorization 20 minus 10 T you can
see that's where I get the x intercept
frogs got to be so careful with your X's
and Y's right and it's going straight
down because it's a straight line and
then you've got acceleration here which
is just a horizontal line and it's
always equal to negative 10 by the way
just because we've gone past this
question now negative 10 always going
down what is this what is this thing
this R this force for the physics people
what is this force that is making the
ball always being pulled
this is gravity right which you'll
frequently see is negative 9.8 but
negative 10 works nicer for numbers and
it's a close enough approximation in
most cases that you'll see it quite
frequently okay right so there are our
graphs so we're actually going to refer
to this a fair bit as we answer the
subsequent questions Part B says find
the speed north the wording of only the
language of the question find the speed
at which the ball was thrown find when
it returns to the ground and show that
it's speed then is equal to its initial
speed okay so let's let's processes
right I want to work out the speed at
which the ball was thrown and when it
landed right so speed comes from
velocity I have a function for velocity
so I'm going to say the velocity at time
zero because don't forget this is
function notation yeah because I have
velocity written as a function of time
so when you write V zero that means at
time zero here's my velocity function
right so when I put in to a zero what do
you get left with just twenty twenty
takeaway zero that's 20 and that's
already positive so don't need to worry
about that as a enough to put absolute
value anything like that it's already a
positive value I can just say that speed
what units are those in by the way what
units 20 meters per second okay so I
should say that that's the velocity now
in order to then work out the second
half of this question where does it
actually hit the ground on my graph I've
already worked this out because I wanted
to graph it with intercepts so can you
see when the ball hits the ground yeah
it starts here and then it returns to
the ground at time four I've stopped my
parabola because I'm just assuming that
um this ball isn't going to borrow
through the ground so it stops at the
ground at time four so therefore I want
velocity at four okay now I want to work
out from this equation I'm just going to
substitute just like I did before this
is a little less trivial even though
it's still pretty easy to work out so
your velocity is going to be have a look
yeah negative 20
and therefore from this I can infer
something about speed right I can say
speed is just the absolute value of
velocity and the velocity is zero its
absolute value also is its velocity at
four when I take the absolute value
okay so there's I'm that's the statement
made right the velocity at initial like
launch is the same as the lost city
sorry the speed when you land okay
because I don't I no longer care about
direction whether it's going up or down
does that make sense